ce que je mets la cravate rouge où est
ce que je mets la cravate bleue si je
mets la cravate rouge elle va me dis
mais pourquoi t'as pas mis la cravate
bleue si je mets à cravate bleue va me
dire mais pourquoi t'as pas vu la
cravate ou c'est ce qu'on appelle une
double contrainte
aujourd'hui je vous propose dans cette
nouvelle vidéo de vous expliquer ce
qu'est la double contrainte est de voir
comment est-ce qu'on peut l'utiliser
dans un cours de sciences sociales la
double contrainte
qu'est ce que c'est la double contrainte
ou double bind va être d'abord formulé
par grigori batson membre éminent de
l'école de palo alto qui est une école
située en californie qui va étudier les
questions de psychologie et de
communication la double contrainte
simplement c'est le fait qu'on vous
donne une injonction qui ne peut pas
être respectées on vous donne un ordre
si vous le respectez vous ne respectez
plus alors ça paraît compliqué comme ça
mais je vais vous donner un exemple si
je vous dis soyez spontanée maintenant
[Musique]
condamnés soyez je prends tu avais joyet
spontanée merci d'avoir été spontanée
et bien voilà c'est une double
contrainte vous ne pouvez pas respecté
ce que je vous dis de faire parce que si
vous mobiliser si vous êtes spontanée
alors vous ne l'êtes plus vous voyez
c'est ça la double contrainte
dans le cas de la cravate à la mer offre
deux cravates à son fils le fils arrive
avec le premier le premier jour avec la
cravate bleue à lui dire mais tu n'as tu
n'as pas mis la rouge tu n'aimes pas la
route
tampa lab le thème pas les cadeaux que
je te fais mais alors s'il vient avec la
roja lui dit exactement l'inversé
donc quelle que soit la cravate qu'il
mais il est toujours perdant dans un
certain sens c'est vraiment ça la double
contrainte on est dans une situation qui
est intenable alors ça pose des
problèmes pour l'individu évidemment qui
est suvi sans cesse à des double
contrainte dans le domaine de la
psychologie qu on a beau sera pas ici la
double contrainte ça peut aussi
apparaître dans l'univers familial enfin
les parents d'un enfant sont séparés et
l'enfant est soumis à un chantage
affectif des deux côtés le père lui dit
mais dis moi que c'est moi que tu
préfères par ben thamer sa mère lui dit
la même chose ou qu'ils aient mis en un
certain sens en tension entre deux pôles
à l'école on pourrait aussi avoir un
enseignant qui va dire d'un élève ont
remis les trophées colère et quand
l'élève finalement prend des largesses à
par rapport aux prescrits aux
prescriptions et aux consignes qui sont
données on va lui dire mais tu ne
respectent pas les consignes de recenser
trop scolaire mais si il s'écarte des
des consignes scolaire à ce moment là on
lui tombe dessus aussi donc c'est aussi
une double contrainte
il ya énormément de double contrainte on
en trouve aussi dans la bande dessinée
comme par exemple dans l'astérix en
corse
oui un légionnaire romain qui est avec
un autochtone et le corps celui dit mais
quoi tu n'aimes pas ma soeur si j'aime
beaucoup votre soeur quoi tu aimes
vraiment ma soeur
le légionnaire romain est perdant
puisque le corps soit lui tomber dessus
dans les deux cas ce qui est intéressant
je trouve avec ce concept de double
contrainte c'est qu'on peut l'utiliser
dans certaines situations sociales dans
certains faits sociaux et notamment par
rapport à certains groupes sociaux qui
sont plus victimes que d'autres de
double contrainte à l'échelle de la
société
on pourrait penser tout d'abord aux
femmes qui dans un sens sont obligés
pour rentrer dans leur dos le moule
qu'on leur concocte dans la société
occidentale vont entrer dans ce moule et
vont directement à voir l'étiquette
d'allumeuse ou de croqueuse d'hommes
traîne femmes pourraient vouloir éviter
cette dérive et à ce moment là ne
faire moins d'efforts par rapport à leur
apparence physique - respecter les
normes qui sont en place par rapport à
cette catégorie sociale et donc elles
vont adopter certains certains
comportements vestimentaires comme par
exemple plus de pantalons mais très peu
moulant le refus de l'épilation le refus
du maquillage et on va leur tomber
dessus aussi
donc dans les deux cas c'est mais elles
sont perdantes puisque dans un cas ça va
être un talus meuse c'est négatif et
d'un autre cas d'un garçon manqué n'est
pas sexy c'est négatif aussi les
personnes d'origine étrangère sont aussi
soumises à de nombreuses doubles
contraintes notamment celles ci une
personne d'origine étrangère qui ne
travaillent pas de sens commun beaucoup
de gens autour de vous on dira que ce
sont des profiteurs finalement les
étrangers viennent ils foutent rien et
voilà il faut leur donner des
allocations pour qu'ils puissent vivre
chez nous ils n'ont qu'à retourner chez
eux
voilà ça c'est la première façon de voir
mais en même temps il ya un discours
tout à fait parallèle et qui place les
personnes d'origine étrangère dans une
situation de double contre si elle vous
viennent à trouver un travail a bien on
va leur dire avec quoi tu as trouvé un
travail
regardez ces étrangers viennent voler le
travail des belges
vous voyez dans les deux cas on est dans
une situation de double contrainte quand
on est une personne d'origine étrangère
puisque dans un premier temps bien si on
travaille pas on est un fainéant dans un
deuxième temps si on travaille on vient
voler le travail des belges ou dans les
deux cas on est perdant il faut bien
être conscient de ces mécanismes de
double contrainte est certainement
essayer soi même en tant qu'individu de
ne pas mettre d'autres personnes dans
une situation de double contrainte un
d'être très claires par rapport à ce que
l'on souhaite c'est très important pour
éviter ce genre de situation soit même
si on est pris dans une situation de
double contrainte ou si un groupe est un
groupe social est pris dans une
situation de double contrainte il faut
essayer de démasquer ce mécanisme est en
le démasque ans on peut le désamorcer
c'est à ça que sert généralement les
soeurs social ça désamorcer certaines
situations peremans dire mais écoute ce
que tu me demandes là c'est irréalisable
puisque je fasse là où je fasse l'autre
ben je suis perdant donc on va soi même
dénoncé le mécanisme de double
contrainte s'est vraiment passé à un
niveau meta est de montrer en quoi
l'injonction paradoxale de la double
contrainte et
à doc salle voilà une vidéo ma foi
salutaire mais j'ai quand même c était
très simplifié donc tout ce que je vous
présente ici ça a été très simplifiées
ces vidéos sont proposés un public
néophyte 1
si vous avez des questions n'hésitez pas
à nous brouiller pas que youtube c'est
un réseau social donc évidemment le
mieux c'est de construire les choses
ensemble moi je vous propose aussi c'est
de vous abonner à ce qu en vous abonnant
vous allez avoir toutes les nouveautés
alors normalement il ya plein de projets
pour la rentrée deux nouvelles vidéos
qui seront faites sur la politique pas
que des vidéos éducatif mais ça sera
toujours dans le cadre la société ecc
donc là je vous propose de vous abonner
bien sûr de liker et à très bientôt
[Musique]